en fin d'étape beaucoup sur les autres
mais on va savoir ce que tu es alors à
faire un test on va prendre toutes les
couleurs comme ça de l'arc en ciel
politique et on va essayer de savoir si
je savais moi même
elle m'envoie pas on va t'aider on va
essayer de savoir à laquelle tu te
réfères vraiment alors rose on peut plus
dire que tu sois rose maintenant tu n'es
plus donc le loubard amis étaient onze
écoute moi j'ai vu des pages dans libé
on avait payé toi avec ton temps les
spas béton et ouais mais ça c'est un
acte de civisme de citoyens qui avaient
les moyens de se payer une page dans le
matin de paris de s'ingérer un des
lecteurs
ouais ouais enfin tu disais tonton
laisse pas béton quand il a vu qu'il y
avait derrière lui les autres les
massacre d'ouvéa là les assassins
bernard pons et compagnie qui arrivent
et les bavures policières malik
oussékine où le gros pasqua n'a pu voler
que surviennent ces bandits ah bon tout
mais pas ça on va voir si tu es rouge tu
as dis je préfèrerais être cubain que
alicia way explique tout cela mais je
préfère cuba les mecs se marre pas
tellement il se marre pas tellement mais
il bouffe et ils ont l'éducation le banc
peut-être pas trop la liberté bon mais
haïti ils sont massacrés opprimés et ils
crèvent de faim en plus je dis je
préférais l'ancien ordre du monde plutôt
que le nouvel ordre du monde celui de
bush
le fabricant savez une union soviétique
très très forte que du travail qu'on y
avait deux corées ouais tu es un seul
centre mou ignoble je préférais qu'il y
avait quand il y avait une force pour
compenser la le capitalisme donc je vais
me relaxer et même avec ses erreurs et
ses excès way jusque là serait plutôt
rouge d'après le test se dit je
chanterai à la fête de l'huma et pas
seulement parce que c'est une grande
fête populaire
là oui quand tu prends de jolis qu'à la
fête de l'huma il va monsieur il ya du
monde
moi j'ai chanté à la fête de l'huma
c'était c'était une façon aussi les
certains engagements est-ce que tu
serais vert parce que là aussi tu aimes
bien les verts mais en même temps tu dis
il y en a pas mal qui sont vert de gris
ouais explique toi bats les vrais verts
sont ceux qui acceptent pas l'ordre
économique mondial tel qu'il est qui
savent que le l'environnement la
pollution tout ça ça sera c'est un
combat perdu d'avancé
si on change pas le système qui fait
qu'il ya un tiers de la planète qui vit
sur les deux autres tiers qu'il ya 85 25
% des des humains et des pays qui
consomme 80 5% des ressources donc la
tvr dans cette limite là ouais
est-ce que tu serais noir les
anarchistes cela qu'il définit rédiger
une certaine tendresse pour les ânes
arbres donc tu serais rouge noir plus
tôt
ses pages étaient des centaines voire
vert rouge noir vert voilà en effet un
rosé pas besoin dix ans mais gérer un
rose je suis pas rose et j'ai toujours
le coeur un peu rose même temps reste
les socialo ils sont gourés il aimait ça
fait dix ans qu'ils sont là être qu'ils
se prennent un peu de vacances malaysie
sion qui s'intéresse beaucoup aux gens
parce que je fais des chansons sur les
problèmes légende le monde comment il va
qu'on ne va pas est-ce que tu connais le
prix d'un ticket de métro sur lequel il
a été posé mais un président de la
république avec l'hypocrisie parce que
ça va faire dix ans je prends pas le
métro et j'en ai pas honte du tout
alors ce que j'aime pas ça tu te
souviens il ya trop de monde et parce
que je suis trop c'est trop et je suis
parano et et puis parce que j'ai une
bagnole beaucoup de rôles bien et que
est ce que c'est ça le côté 3 france 5
ans je sais pas c'est pas à moi non plus